well first off if you talk to the
brainiacs you know with their parchments
and Public Safety from Ivy League
schools or even from junior colleges
they'll swear to you that citizen arrest
is a vigilante act I've been with police
superintendents I've been in think tanks
and he's so-called quote police
scientists will tell me it's a vigilante
act they don't have to argue with them
that it's in the Penal Code it's been
written about it's been embedded into
the fabric of law since the Magna Carta
in England and can be seen in virtually
laws written all over the world because
we have guardian angels now in 14
countries 140 cities so I'm well-versed
in it and it gives you a much wider
leeway and breadth of activity where you
can physically intervene then it would
even a lot of police officer because the
courts assume that a police officer as
he or she is is a trained police
professional who's gone to the Academy
they know the differences between
violations misdemeanors felonies and the
use of force whereas the citizen is
assumed and rightfully so not to be as
expert so if they decide to intervene as
long as it's within the parameters of
what they can do guess what I can use
more force than the police officer can
and whereas a police department is
represented by a municipality a county
or a state government so let's assume
they have big pockets you know they're a
big fat cow ready to be brought to the
slaughterhouse by the liars for hire the
spin doctors who ambulance chasers by
day and go at night to funeral parlors
giving out business cards practicing
their martial art I sue they're looking
to sue obviously for the most minor of
indiscretions against the police officer
but when it comes to a citizen who
doesn't have two nickels to rub together
and throws them around like manhole
covers then that is willing to go in
that direction so is it a reality can
you be sued is it something that in
which you inherit upon yourself
potential danger to yourself danger to
somebody else civil liability criminal
liability of course but it shouldn't
give you an X lakhs attack and make you
fear to the point where you're frozen
solid as a result of your inability to
respond as a Good Samaritan should do
now having applied it now
it's thousands of times in venues all
over the world I can tell you this it's
a Chinese menu there are three ways to
do it and I've become very proficient at
doing it so much so that in 31 years we
haven't been sued once for making a
citizen's arrest
even though we've done thousands of
interventions hundreds of citizens
arrests where lawyers would love to have
a notch of the guardian angels on their
belt just for the tabloid headlines that
it would create for their legal business
and that's that not hasn't happened